es sieht aus wie in einem kriegsgebiet
überall nur noch unterm ente und den
häusern meiner freunde bei meinem
eigenen haus verheerend
[Musik]
wie ist es ein haus zu verlieren
du verlierst einen teil von ein stolzer
amerikanischer soldat pedro korea im
irak zu kämpfen habe ihm keine angst
gemacht auch die terroranschläge von
nani leben nicht wo er leben rettete
aber dann kam dieser hurrikan mit dem
niedlichen namen sandy
die wellen immer höher schlagen wusste
ich etwas stimmt nicht
das haus dort die plötzlich auf dem
wasser es kracht ins nachbarhaus und
spaltete es in der mitte
der wird dort herzlich willkommen auf
der fanpage ich bete zu gott für meine
frau an und sagen ich werde sterben mit
seinem bruder konnte er sich an eine
tischplatte wurde ins landesinnere
geschwemmt prallte dort auf schott und
fiel ins kalte wasser
mit letzter kraft sparen wir zu einem
haus drinnen realisierte ich habe
überlebt ehrlich gesagt das war
großartig
petrus geschichte ist die geschichte
einer nation die sich früher auf retter
der welt feierte und von dem man sich
heute fragt ob sie sich noch selber
helfen kann
acht jahre sind vergangen seit dem
todessprung katrina als die regierung
bush versorgt hatte
wurden daraus lehren gezogen oder hat
sich das drama bei sandy wiederholt
wir dulden keine bürokratie wo steht die
welt macht heute und wie steht es um die
dauer ab die miss muss der amerikaner
[Musik]
abseits vom glanz der metropole
manhattan und eine ford mit der orangen
fähre entfernt liegt städten island
[Musik]
sie würden zur stadt new york gehören
aber man vergesse sie gerne sagen die
station eilender leute des unteren
mittelstandes ein monat ist seit der
jahrhundertflut vergangen
es ist dezember und eigentlich wollen
die behörden informieren
die reden doch nur wir wollen zurück in
unsere häuser sollen sie doch in zell
kleben nicht so
alle reden durcheinander ich verstehe
nichts beruhigt euch ich habe keinen
strom keine heizung nicht mal eine
abwasserleitung aber ein staat beamter
sagt mir ich könnte in meinem haus leben
ein witz wir haben euch gewählt ihr
arbeitet für uns einen kilometer vom
meer entfernt liegt großes haus 164 roma
avenue bei scott sind in diesen tagen
alle besucher willkommen es scheint als
wolle der kaufmännische angestellte sein
elend in die ganze welt hinausschreien
das war mein wohnzimmer
wir hatten einen neuen
flachbildfernseher aber der verkäufer
sagt keine garantie bei
naturkatastrophen
am schlimmsten aber sei die staatliche
flut versicherung immer habe er ein
bezahlt aber jetzt kommen sie nur für
die hälfte des schadens auf wie sollen
er und seine frau die twitter
wiederaufbau der staat zwinge sie schon
zu machen
seit einem monat nun leben sie ohne
küche bad und klo scott demonstriert wo
er seine notdurft verrichtet so machen
wir das dieses land schickt milliarden
an hilfsgeldern in andere länder bei uns
aber verhungern und sterben leute unsere
leute haben mehr menge geld zu bekommen
als das ausland
[Musik]
sie müssen uns helfen wir sind extrem
frustriert dort hinten ist ein tisch
geben sie namen und telefonnummern wir
werden sie anrufen
wir werden herum gejagt von
katastrophenschutz zur
hausratsversicherung meine bezahlt
läppische 150 teuer
nicole wohnt nur wenige häuser von scott
und chaudry entfernt und der topping
street 38 weil ihr haus nicht mehr
bewohnbar ist finanziert der staat
vorübergehend eine mietwohnung das ist
überlebenswichtig denn nicole muss ihre
hypothek weiterbezahlen sie sagt das
fundament sei nicht mehr stabil
darum will sie das haus abreißen und neu
aufbauen lassen
dieser erschien jahre des new yorker
amts für bauten sollen hier amtlich
bestätigen dass der abriss unumgänglich
ist
somit würde die stadt dafür aufkommen
nicoles problem ihr haus sieht schlecht
aus aber andere häuser sehen noch
schlechter aus erklären sie mir warum
sie den abriss nicht bezahlen das machen
wir nur beim total und stabilen gebäuden
das heißt also das haus ist stabil wenn
ich hier stehen und auf dem boden hin
und her schaukeln
für nicole und ihre familie geht es um
alles wird der abriss nicht bezahlt
müssen sie das haus aufgeben und
privatkonkurs anmelden
das ist kein backsteinbau das ist unser
zuhause
hier habe ich essen gekocht und meiner
tochter gute nacht geschichten
vorgelesen
wir wollen doch nur nach hause
die rückstände einer katastrophe eine
katastrophe die viel hausgemachtes an
sich hat im amerika von apple google und
microsoft ist es normal im holz pangallo
zuhause überirdisch hängende kabel sind
die regel
in der karibik sieht es nicht viel
anders aus sehen sie das problem dass
die infrastruktur hier einem
drittweltland entspricht
das waren früher ferienhäuser aber das
ist doch schon lange nicht erst seit 50
jahren hält man das ganze jahr über hier
ist es darum nicht wichtig dass die
regierung bauvorschriften herausgibt
müssen sie die leute halten sich einfach
nicht daran
[Musik]
es ist nichts mit wir haben alles
die gsm mio das epizentrum der
verwüstung
[Musik]
eine katastrophe entblößt die seele
eines landes die arbeiter reagieren
wütend die patrioten trotzig und dann
gibt es noch die strenggläubigen
amerikaner sowie die familie von
laienprediger joseph beuys und der macht
sich seine ganz eigenen gedanken zur
jahrhundertflut
das ist ein urteilsspruch über amerika
und das ist erst der anfang
gott ist nicht froh dass amerika ihm den
rücken zugewandt hat was konkret meinen
sie ich geschlechtliche drogen
homosexualität abtreibung der mensch
verdreht biblischen worte zu sein nutzen
[Musik]
ihre häuser zerstört der amerikanische
traum zerplatzt die kirche symbolisch
fast für eine weltmacht die mehr und
mehr verfällt man spricht ja immer vom
amerikanischen optimismus sind sie noch
ein optimist ich bin ein amerikanischer
soldat
ich glaube fest an dieses land ich habe
diesen land gedient
das letzte was ich tun würde ich dieses
land wieder einen film zu kritisieren
egal was passiert nicht wahr
egal was passiert ich habe meinem land
gedient mein land in ihr gedient die
kriegswirren behörde hat mir geholfen
dieses haus zu kaufen
sonst hätte ich es mir nicht leisten
können
die regierung hat ihm geholfen ein haus
zu kaufen das unter dem meeresspiegel
inmitten von sumpfland liegt das meer
praktisch ungeschützt vor der haustür
heute ist allen klar hier hätte nie
gebaut werden dürfen
hier stand mal eine behelfsmäßige art
von strand mauer sie warum zwei meter
hoch das ding ist gesunken
die mauer hätte besser und höher gebaut
werden müssen
mit den jahren wurde sie löchrig es gab
ein feuer das einen teil der mauer dort
drüben zerstört vier jahre ist das hier
vier jahre vergingen seit dem feuer und
nichts geschah seite wurden unsere
häuser überschwemmt wir sagten den
politikern die mauer müsse repariert
werden
das dauert alles zu lange alles dauerte
zu lange und sogar noch viel länger wie
ich merke 20 jahre nämlich schon 1993
wollten die us-behörden die küste von
staten island besser schützen vor 20
jahren glauben sie eine studie in
auftrag dort steht die gegend hat eine
lange geschichte von sturmschäden nur
mit dem bau eines damms wurde bis heute
nicht begonnen für den dammbau zuständig
ist das militärdepartement ein interview
wird zugesagt verschoben und einen monat
später vom pressesprecher mit auf
wichtigster entschuldigung abgesagt
fragen aber könne er telefonisch
beantwortet insight in einem editor
behörde in den letzten 20 jahren einen
großen dann gebaut hätte wenn die häuser
nicht zerstört worden
sehen sie noch da ja warte eine frage
sehen sie den punkt dass das militär
leben gefährdet haut war 20 jahre lang
nichts gebaut wurde
wir können nur etwas tun wenn wir geld
bekommen
der kongress sprach zu wenig geld für
die studie während jahren wo sie
gestoppt weil keine mittel kam könnte
das kind nicht schneller kommen
ich weiß nicht wer diese frage
beantworten könnte
ich spreche mit demselben angst dass
beim bau der deiche in valence versagt
hatte
vor acht jahren im zuge von hurrikan
katrina kam die militärbehörde unter
beschuss aus die deiche brachen und rund
1800 menschen starben
darum gehen diese studien ja solange sie
müssen sicherstellen dass sie korrekt
durchgeführt werden sie können das nicht
forcieren
wie geht es etwas besser
hast du eine wohnung ja eine
provisorische plan
das war hart unglaublich aber wir kommen
durch
natürlich wir sind widerstandsfähig die
schau nach vorn
durchhalteparolen wie man sie aus
amerika kennt dabei ist ihre zukunft
völlig unklar
sie wollen weg von hier aber sie haben
kein geld die staatliche flut
versicherung hat ihnen zwar je eine
viertelmillion versprochen das geld
bekommen sie aber nur wenn sie am
gleichen ort wieder aufbauen
die situation an der kissen sie scheint
ausweglos
[Musik]
hilft hier die regierung nicht so sagt
nicole vier monate nach dem sturm zu
hilf dir selbst ihr amerikanischer traum
sei tot aber nicht irland
denn es seien die menschen die amerika
ausmachen
nicole wie geht's es geht wie du siehst
ja aber wie geht es dir monate später
heute wunderbar wohl nichts zu tun gibt
es neuigkeiten in bezug auf dein haus
nicoles nachbars korps ist seit der
turbulenten bürgerversammlung der ganzen
nation bekannt der republikaner ist
unterdessen dauergast beim rechts-
konservativen sender fox news
ich habe zu präsident obama gesagt sie
versprachen uns unbürokratische hilfe
ich sagte herr präsident sie haben das
amerikanische volk angelogen
sie sind nach erwarten die ferien
gegangen während ich um meine nachbarn
in kaputten häusern gefroren haben aber
sie haben unser steuergeld genommen um
sich mit ihrer familie zu vergnügen
wie aber steht es um die
eigenverantwortung die republikaner bis
kurz sonst so sehr preisen es nicht ein
fehler hier im sumpfgebiet zu bauen weil
es nicht
[Musik]
unterdessen an der kissen avenue
abgesang auf das heim von laien for
mercy
für gotteslohn ist seine familie bei
mitgliedern ihrer kirchgemeinde
untergekommen
das ganze ist schwierig zu verdauen
es sind nur materielle dinge und doch
waren es unsere sorten für die wir so
lange gearbeitet haben
aber gott wird alles wieder herstellen
das ist meine einbürgerungsurkunde
ich finde es unglaublich dass wir sie
retten konnten aber sie ist in einem
ziemlich schlechten zustand ja das
könnte man so sagen
ich kenne leider nie und ihren mann nun
schon seit monaten aber heute erst
erzählen sie mir dass sie sich ihr
zerstört das traumhaus gar nie hätten
leisten können
sie hatten es ohne eigenkapital gekauft
und vermochten nicht die hypothek von
5000 dollar monatlich zu bezahlen
die zwangsräumung drohte und dann kam
sein
ich hatte gestern das gefühl ich hätte
einen herzinfarkt
aber ich sagte mir anderes ist wichtiger
ich muss weiter funktionieren
wir lernen unsere lektion sehr
schmerzlich ich bin zimmermann sie ist
krankenschwester wir hatten noch nie
geld auf der hohen kante
unser glaube etwas zu uns heraus geführt
[Musik]
und während die pfarrersfamilie betet
dass gott sie aus dieser misere befreien
möge hat eine nachbars gruppe an plan
entwickelt der staat soll ihre nicht
mehr bewohnbaren häuser aufkaufen ein
sogenannter bayard eine fremdfinanzierte
übernahme nur geht es hier nicht um
hochfliegende manager dienst sondern ums
überleben von arbeiterfamilien wir alle
wollen dass unsere häuser aufgekauft
werden
aber wir müssen die behörden überzeugen
wir haben viel recherchiert und wissen
jetzt das geld kommt aus washington
betrieben wird das programm aber vom
staat mio unsere anmeldungen wiederum
müssen wir bei der stadt einreichen
die frage ist nur bei wem wir versuchen
jetzt herauszufinden wie das
funktioniert das ganze wird ein bis zwei
jahre dauern bis dann bin ich bankrott
das nützte alles nichts
auch pedro hat sich zu sehr verschuldet
darum braucht er schnell hilfe darum
lässt in der amtsschimmel der usa
verzweifeln jetzt möchte ich dass wir
den fernen alt bieten
trotz allem und immer wieder leisten sie
den treueschwur auf das land das sie das
beste der welt nennen
eines tages werden wir wieder in unseren
häusern seien auch ein halbes jahr nach
dem sturm kämpft nicole noch immer dafür
dass die stadt new york den abbruch
ihres hauses finanziert
nikos nachbar der rechtsaußen
republikaner scott brown unterdessen mit
hilfe von freunden wieder auf
[Musik]
und die männer von der kissinger pedro
und josef haben glück im unglück der
staat new york hat dem aufkauf ihre
häuser am strand unerwartet schnell
zugestimmt
finanziell sind die familien damit
weitgehend über den berg für die
regierung ist es billiger unsere häuser
aufzukaufen hat endlich den damm zu
bauen
ich lebte hier meinen traum den
amerikanischen traum aber ist vorbei
im amerika des stolzen soldaten pedro
korea wird sich diese geschichte
wiederholen und jedes mal wird man
erstaunt sein sich beklagen um dann doch
ein comeback zu schaffen irgendwie und
genau das ist der amerikanische traum
oder vielmehr das ist das wunder von
amerika